the BBC prepares secret scripts for
possible use in Winter blackouts
wonderful Scripps set out how
Corporation will reassure public an
event of major power loss well if you
live in a city as dense as London and
there's no power good luck I don't know
what they would do that's a that's a
massively dense City with no energy how
long until the water stops flowing how
long till there's no food everything
spoils in the dead of winter especially
when you can't heat your pipes the water
is going to of course create so much
damage all throughout you know the city
center it's absolutely mind-boggling to
understand how fragile our current
civilization is and what kind of a big
mess our politicians are getting us into
deliberately we have to understand these
are not policies that were just
accidentally created these were policies
that were fomented that were built that
were tested on other societies and are
being introduced right now all under the
umbrella of the great reset all under
the umbrella of taking care of the
environment meanwhile they are
deliberately limiting energy to people
so they could limit human potential this
is all a deliberate plan and people have
to really stand up for themselves
because if they don't the mess is
extremely serious it's already going to
hit everyone very very hard very soon I
just I just want to you know I point
this out whenever we talk about
blackouts but diabetics are at serious
risk because insulin needs to be
refrigerated if power goes out this is
this is seriously bad for people who are
diabetic you know they're going to lose
their lives
um now if it's in Winter I don't know
how cold it gets in London perhaps it
will be cold enough outside where they
can get a cooler maybe they can take
snow or something and they can yeah they
can they can keep their medicine
um uh their insulin at the right
temperature but even outside of that in
the winter when you can't heat your
homes yeah food's gonna food's gonna
spoil I suppose though in Winter you put
the food outside yeah it won't be as bad
but then you've hotter Summers every
year in London now I wonder though is
the reason they're concerned about
blackouts is because of heating your
home is is that the principal
consumption of energy yeah because they
don't have air condition
environmentalist again this Global
environmentalist uh I don't know uh
conspiracy almost but I don't what's
like what's behind it like why are they
saying that there's going to be
blackouts uh War I mean it's a secret
script right uh yeah possible but is it
is it war is it
um lack of energy yeah so with the war
in Russia
you know nordstream they just posted
video from the nordstream attack it's an
attack now at this point 165 feet of the
pipeline was blown off and is missing
that is not an accident that is a huge
chunk that's massive it's what is that
165 fees that half a football field yeah
yeah that makes her have I don't know
more than half yeah more than half so it
says 300 feet right 100 yards yeah like
70 60 feet no no no it's less than half
would you say 100 165. okay more than
half a football and was it only one spot
I thought it was or you know I think
there were a couple different well they
they uh maybe the the hits were in
different spots and then caused it to
fall off or whatever they know what they
hit it with no well we don't I mean they
wonder if they lined it with Nano
thermite and we know you did this we
know you did this why would Putin blow
up his own pipeline yeah it makes no
sense so they cut off uh the flow into
Europe Russia does Russia starts you
know uh oh now we've got this report
which I I've only seen it from South uh
south of uh African sources but you were
mentioning The Surge that they uh Saudi
Arabia wants to join brics what's that
ramfosa ramaphosa is that um yeah he's
the current president so you saw that
story is that true
um my family at chat had it going on in
the WhatsApp forever ago but that he's
saying Saudi Arabia wants to join bricks
yeah like like in the recent past yes
yes right so apparently he posted on a
social media saying this is going to
happen if that happens that is
apocalyptic already the Saudis are
cutting oil production Russia is a part
of OPEC plus this means that they're
going to keep being able to sell gas at
a premium it's going to sell to China
China is going to sell to Europe Europe
is getting strangled out come winter
we already saw the videos of Italy of
cafes in Italy Candlelight cash
transactions sorry when remember when uh
Texas got so cold that it and the
because of the energy or the power went
out and all of that that happened in
Texas I mean that's Texas we're talking
about London here we're talking about a
lot colder and the Mayhem that it caused
in Texas was
you know they're still they're still
recovering from that is the war worth it
it's a lot of you know the policies that
they've been laying forward that has
been deliberately denying people energy
and this is not a problem that's only
going to be around for the next few
months this is a problem that's going to
be around for the next few years uh the
telegraph is reporting that the National
Grid warns of a three-year energy crisis
as a National Emergency it is something
that that they cannot get away from they
just started to announce that they're
going to be fracking inside of the
United Kingdom but but energy is key to
human success to human prosperity and
again there is an agenda to limit that
specifically in in Ukraine right now
one-third of the power stations have
been destroyed as the World Health
Organization is of course warning about
a brutal winter ahead there's going to
be a lot of ramifications because of the
foreign policy because of the domestic
policy that has led us to this age where
we're literally going back to the Stone
Age why are we doing this well all in
the name of helping the environment it
and it's not helping the environment
it's not helping anyone we're just
literally buying uh you know patched
over guest from Russia to China that
they're just shipping to to Europe right
now which is only making sure that
people lose more of their money and
can't afford to even live and and afford
a basic lifestyle so let me let me ask
you uh Ammon you guys you've been
ranching for a long time you've got
animals do you have more than cattle
you've probably got oh yeah but you know
of course horses and
all the chickens and that but mostly you
know cattle is where we make our money
off of them if the apocalypse happened
right now would your family be all right
yeah we'd be fine totally fine yeah
would you would you even notice like I
mean obviously you notice in the news
but like would it impact your your daily
food consumption is I mean Amazon
wouldn't show up you know yeah so
there'd be that of course we would be
affected but we would have food you know
we'd have supplies what do you do about
toilet paper that's why everybody lost
their minds and started fighting in this
in supermarkets for days
or a leaf like a big leaf or something
like that right yeah yeah but uh no but
in all seriousness I ask because
um it's funny I mean I think people in
London would start eating each other
within a few days yeah I'm okay
realistically within like a week or so
so we might just look at London what's
going on over there well in Idaho good
old conservative Idaho there's the
Democrats there along with the uh
several establishment Republicans
they're trying to remove five dams uh
hydropower that's a primary source of
energy trying to get rid of that trying
to get rid of them why for the salmon
they believe that the Salmon's got a
good but this is green energy this is
exactly what they wanted none of them
makes sense well it makes sense if you
if their goal is to get rid of people to
reduce population that's the only way it
makes sense right I said it many many
times you're exactly right everything
they do look The Conspiracy Theory as I
mentioned would be the intent to reduce
population we know Bill Gates has given
speeches on reducing population growth
so we know he's he's concerned about
there being too many people
if you look at everything they do take
intent out of it don't think conspiracy
just say hey all those things result in
less people
that's exactly right telling the
Netherlands to stop farming when there's
a food shortage looming shutting down
power plants when there's an energy
crisis telling Sri Lanka to get rid of
fertilizers well that's exactly right
it's all that's why I say it stinks of
that Global Environmental movement and
it's it's a deep delegation agenda this
is the problem with global
environmentalism is if they want to stop
oil production because it's dirty so
then we run out of electricity people
get desperate they go to war nuclear
bombs go off create a nuclear winter
with three years of no sunlight all the
Farms go dead talk about destroying the
environment environmentalists nuclear
war is the worst thing for the
environment that could possibly happen
right now next to an asteroid but pieces
are dangerous peace is dangerous didn't
you see that at some point you just got
to burn the coal and then recapture the
carbon well I got to correct you and
they're not just trying to get rid of
oil they're just buying it from Saudi
Arabia instead of domestically exploring
and and getting it out of the ground
here and importing it or they're doing
it from China just like they're doing in
Europe and that confirms uh the South
African president serial ramaphoso did
say this is from seven hours ago the
Crown Prince of Saudi Arabia did Express
Saudi Arabia's desire to be part of
bricks
that's from en.trend.az and then I also
saw that bricks expects Egypt Saudi
Arabia and turkey to join the group so
what would that be then Egypt turkey and
Saudi Arabia yeah
it'll be bricks plus
with the letters but I mean that's
turkey is Russia's Outlet into the
Mediterranean so that makes sense there
Egypt no NATO Saudi Arabia is Just
Turkey they're protecting the Suez Canal
they want that trade route into the
Mediterranean where is the food in the
first nuke land because I'm chilling you
know I don't think it'll happen but
it'll be an air burst if it did well
yeah I know of course but like over what
city
no think false flag first not Kiev
absolutely not I I think why not Kiev
though
um too much civilian population I know
it's shocking off yeah but that's that's
that's a lot of death I think it's gonna
happen with the entire population
there's a lot of military uh equipment
and a lot of uh military infrastructure
in kharkiv
Kevin Martin are like historically
important to the Russian the Russian
people is there another thing yeah
there's a lot of history there yes
there's a lot of blood there there's a
lot of suffering there there's lots of
years in the capital of Russia like
hundreds of years ago or something
that's that's what I was asking about
yeah sure yeah I think so there you go
but I don't think I think I think Putin
wants the Don bass region to connect to
Crimea he wants to control more of the
Black Sea yeah so
well yeah I don't think he wants a
destruction of the world that's for sure
now who does we live here right you know
that's why I always find super villains
funny it's like I'm going to destroy the
planet it's like okay you live here dude
I think another possibility is that he
might just go to the Black Sea and just
explode something there as a show of
force as a show of power I think that's
also one possibility just to be like
look what I could do let me let's let's
negotiate uh so again lots of
negotiations lots of uh you know it's a
big chess game uh geopolitically that's
unfolding right now but uh I I don't see
Kiev I see a major key piece of uh the
war machine being affected here and I
think also as you mentioned before
there's a big possibility of a false
flag attack uh since of course there's
even U.S made nuclear weapons that have
gone missing so there's there's also a
lot of russian-made nuclear weapons that
gone that that were disappeared and are
missing so so what a big potential here
for for someone a bad actor to come in
and to create a lot of chaos that they
would benefit off of what if he nukes
like just sends like 100 100 nukes right
into Antarctica just just like Mars The
Martian well no the thing about he did
it Antarctica is that the ice is all on
a landmass so that it actually would
raise ocean levels if the Ice broke off
and went to the water what if he just
went like full comic book villain was
like you know I'm not going to lose so I
won't nuke you I'll nuke Antarctica and
then they're like oh no and there's no
defensive capabilities there so you know
what do you do
I mean it is kind of silly but there's
things like that you gotta think outside
the box he could say okay I won't nuke
you you can't retell it against me but I
can hit the ice caps dude I watched the
nuclear winner you got to watch a video
on nuclear winter because what happens
is oh yeah the nukes go off black clouds
over the everything for three years and
then it just covers the entire planet
yeah and the radiation is there for
hundreds of thousands of years
like unless they plan on going
underground with canned food for three
years and then coming back up and being
the ruler of a dead Planet I don't
understand the methodology bro Raven
Rock like I I look I wouldn't be
surprised if they have underground Farms
oh yeah probably they do absolutely yeah
um I think we need to appeal to
zielinski right now because he's the guy
that will listen to the America like
he's a he's an actor he's an Entertainer
he likes being loved he's I don't think
he's a horrible guy like At first I
wanted to hate him because of his but
like the position come on he's a puppet
president but like at the same time it's
it's in his lap if he wants to negotiate
with Putin right now no it isn't the
only person on Earth that can make this
happen is Vladimir I disagree who else
could do could start the negotiations
though because it's up to him the United
States of NATO you could say that that
Biden and Putin could do it today also
the European Union passed the law that
allows Ukrainian soldiers to be trained
in Europe uh and they will be trained
specifically in Poland and in Germany
and and again a lot of people don't
realize this proxy conflict could last a
very long time it could last 10 years it
could last 20 years when we look at
these kind of sectarian conflicts with
you know the borders so close to each
other they escalate very quickly they
de-escalate very slowly and the conflict
is always going to be there so this is
something that's going to be a a hotbed
for a lot of trouble for the future so
you know again negotiations peace deals
being able to come together no one is
going to be fully happy but but but I
think we should still push for them two
coming together but the United States
NATO has to be a part of those
conversations because they're the ones
fueling this war they're the ones
financing this war they're the ones
making this war possible and that's why
they need to be at the table they need
to negotiate because if zielinski went
off on his own and was like I'm going to
negotiate you think NATO would have him
removed from Power well they were very
close to having negotiations they were
very close to zielinski and Pooh and
even coming together they had a meeting
they had a date that the two people were
supposed to come together and then
Western leaders came to zielinski said
no you're not going to meet with Putin
no you're not going to negotiate with
them no you're not going to have any
kind of Peace deals here and zelinski
said okay here's what I think would
happen if zelenski came out right now
and gave a speech and he said I'm going
to meet with Vladimir Putin to negotiate
an end of this conflict for the sake of
preserving the world and preventing
World War III half an hour would go by
and CNN would go breaking news zelenski
was killed in a car bomb it was Putin
who did it exploiting the fact that he
was trying to negotiate peace showing
just how evil he really was the new
second in command vice president has
taken over is even more war hawkish and
then it's going to cut to it guys and be
like I love America and that's there you
go that's my prediction or they could
just use the CGI hologram version of
them you know who knows there's a lot of
different possibilities but there's a
lot of psyops there's a lot of
disinformation there's a lot of
propaganda but at the end of the day
there's a lot of Life loss a lot of
innocent people are getting screwed over
or getting hurt we need to stop that
immediately and sadly all we have are
neocon warmongering bloodthirsty
warhawks who are saying more war more
death more destruction that to me is
absolutely insane and stupid and
literally is risking the existence of
our civilization why what's the end goal
what's the objective is it really
risking the civilization absolutely if
when they've got underground bunkers
like Raven Rock and mount weather and
that's just the ones we know about okay
sorry if the benefit of the 0.001 no
exactly the people who have their finger
on the button are like I don't care what
happens I'll be fine it'd be a new
civilization our civilization would be
there's a limited space station well I
live in a big Space Station underground
I used to I have a friend Zach router
who who says uh that Civilization is the
fall of this civilization is falling I'm
like well no no it's this one particular
he would say that Civilization is the
downfall of humanity what we've done and
I'm thinking it's this civilization
that's on the back of oil that's
obsessed with like non-reproducible
energy sources and and food consumption
that is that's causing it yeah because I
think if we lived in harmony with nature
if we were getting energy out of the
vacuum that we could subsist if we were
like you know creating life and then
consuming that as opposed to just eating
what's already there
um so you're talking about finding a way
to harness Zero Point Energy yeah
exactly like the vibration of the vacuum
and stuff like that
um but I don't know enough about it but
but I've read a bit about it now I think
it's it's interesting I mean Fusion is
going to be huge but I'm not con against
that there are some people who have
argued that fossil fuels they're they're
not necessarily uh as funded as we think
and that they're constantly in a state
of production it's it's not dinosaurs
it's algae that gets compressed and
they've actually synthesized petroleum
this way so cool but I don't have it but
I think I think the real issue for these
people clearly is
energy dense resources like uh petroleum
results in more human beings and too
many human beings means you lose control
of the system right and if everybody had
their own energy source then you'd have
even more exponential exponential growth
of humans which could become an even now
imagine how much how much prosperous
Humanity would be if we had free energy
we would need to make moves fast because
if we get too many people on earth with
unlimited energy they'll blow each other
up I mean if we have free energy we can
just make space stations and leave and
go colonize the universe if we don't
have the technology like produce food
and water out of the vacuum then the
energy is useless it's just going to
make people get hot and blow people up
it's all about just converting to their
I mean everything is Just Energy you got
to convert it and mash things together
and structure it properly it's it's
still sci-fi doesn't mean it's not going
to happen but our civilization is on the
back of like a non-renewable resource
that it needs to seek out in mind like
you're saying they want Mining rights
because they want those non-renewables
and uh and that would end up that's
renewable
an energy source well like
hydroelectricity
so aren't there components in
hydroelectric dams that have to be
replaced and repaired yeah renewable is
a it doesn't mean that it lasts forever
100 so we're still gonna have to mine
and search for minerals to make those
energy sources yeah you probably have
like one thousandth of the mining would
be nice if you had stuff like that or
like power like the amount I I think
you're making a lot of assumptions
because you don't pick it up a number I
mean you know the amount of using let's
propaganda terms right winds terms
require a ton of oil
to make to run yeah they don't they
lubricants they cost more than than the
power would cost I don't know much about
so wind turbines have an extremely low
energy return on energy investment it's
like 0.4 I mean it I think it it might
be above one but it might be like 1.4
whereas like petroleum is like 30 and
nuclear power is like 50. so that that
means for every for every calorie you
put it you put you put an investment you
get X output nuclear is the best yeah I
believe Fusion is pretty regenerative
and fusion is I think the absolute best
we have so far but petroleum is just
it's massive it's easy to get I think I
think if the government was had been out
of the way for the last 30 years when it
come to energy meaning stop subsidizing
stop regulating stop controlling that we
would have already found a much better
way to create energy but because of the
government's regulations controls I mean
nuclear nuclear energy is is about as
efficient as you're going to get uh as
far as what we have developed in in
technology today but the governments
won't let us use it on the scale that we
should be using it
um right so but if the government was
out of the way and there was
deregulation if you will and I know
that's a scary word for a lot of people
and they were not subsidizing I believe
we would have a lot of answers already
when it comes to energy yeah yeah I
think so too I think it's intentionally
controlling the the output the valve
because they don't want too many people
yeah Bingo you you if nuclear energy was
the norm the energy return is higher
than petroleum so you look at that map
on another map the chart showing
population and then petroleum skyrockets
within the span of like one generation
it's insane we went from having around
500 million people on this planet for
hundreds of years to billions and it's
because of Technology the machinery for
plants uh making you know for farming as
well as the ease easy access of energy
we upgrade from petroleum to nuclear
which is an even better return and it's
going to be another exponential massive
increase and I'm all for it just build
spaceships and let's go send those
spaceships out you know put a bunch of
people on them and bye-bye I think
every person and don't quote me on this
but I'm pretty sure I'm pretty close
every person in Idaho can have like 22
acres to themselves
you know not that we want that that
people to come to Idaho but yeah please
don't uh yeah but uh please don't you
know and Nevada's even Nevada is like 88
acres or something like that well the
interesting thing is we're terraforming
Vegas
because here's how it works Vegas is a
desert
people fly there and when those planes
come it brings water and human waste
from other cities and then people land
and they you know take their dumps and
their peeps in Vegas all of that stays
there so we're bringing massive amounts
of moisture in our own waste not right I
don't know about human fertilizer I
don't think they've met but it is
creating it is bringing moisture then
also when they ship food in to feed all
these people that creates more moisture
so now I was reading how there's clouds
and there's grass growing they brought
in grass for houses because people like
it that's retaining moisture we're
basically it's a man-made man-made
terraforming of of uh the desert yeah
yeah Lake Meadville it's drying up quick
but there but they're going to keep
shipping the water in yeah they're not
going to let it you know collapse it's
crazy it's crazy I yeah it's it's it
makes you wonder what they're going to
do you know how they might so my dad's
Ranch is like 20 miles well was 20 many
miles just north of Lake Mead the very
typical Mead and now it's like 35 miles
so wow do you know that that old city
that reappeared what it was called St
Thomas yes yeah yeah I went there under
the under the Lake Mead yeah and then
when it dried up all of a sudden the
foundations and everything appeared and
people started going out and taking
pictures of and stuff I got to go there
and they found all those dead bodies
from them really yeah they found a whole
bunch that they thought would never show
up again it makes sense because they
were out of Vegas for so long that's
right yeah it's crazy walking through
the desert because there's like plants
everywhere and you can't tell but
there's boat parts because people were
you know the bottom right and now it's
all dried up now and like it came back
for a while but it's once it's down way
down it's way down it's down further it
came up a little bit and then went way
down it's all that global warming you
don't bring in the end of the end is not
a lot of that's going to California not
just Vegas yeah they're wiping a lot of
it to Southern California oh the Lake
Mead water
I think the bulk of a deck is actually
going to you know California it is yeah
interesting water rights uh that's the
guy who was it Michael burry the guy who
the big short I don't know if you saw
that movie where he he's he like oh
right said hey the 2008 uh housing
crisis is coming he was the one that
figured it out he says water's the next
big investment I remember him yeah so
he's investing in like food transport
and stuff like that
but again if we if we would get the
government out of the way we would
figure out a way to you know to re renew
water because moisture doesn't leave the
atmosphere I mean it doesn't so you just
it just goes different places and it has
to be used in a different way or or
benefited in a different way so we would
find ways to to you know either get the
salt out of the ocean or whatever it
might be yeah I'm concerned with getting
the government out of the way completely
because of like Nestle buying up water
rights and land like corporations
becoming the new government if we don't
have Anti-Trust that's what California
is basically the reason all that water's
been taken up in California is for
almonds number one and then also a lot
of the other water being bottled up
Vanessa which is a smaller a smaller
portion of it but still significant the
government protects Nestle and allows
them to do that correct yeah well so
yeah and the other you know like not to
build on that too much because it'd be
boring to talk about but like the the
courts are where like if someone's
rights are violated we need the courts
to go to and try to work it out but what
we don't need is the government going in
and doing all these uh preventive you
know laws that actually make it so that
we can't use the natural resources or we
can't be free if if Nestle is like you
know putting toxic waste inside in in
into the rivers or whatever they might
be doing then the courts are there for
the people to say look we're going to
take Nestle to to court we're going to
sue them and stop them from this but for
the government to come in and like say
we're going to regulate and control the
entire process so no one benefits I I
think I think that's where we where
we've gone wrong thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there